>>> AN HISTORIC DAY IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
THE JANUARY 6th SELECT COMMITTEE
JUST RECMENDING THAT DONALD
TRUMP BE PROSECUTED ON FOUR
CRIMINAL CHARGES MAKING THE CASE
THAT THE VIOLENT ATTACK ON THE
U.S. CAPITOL AND OTHER EVENTS OF
THAT DAY WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT HIM.
THE ALL ROADS LEAD TO DONALD
TRUMP.
THEY ARE VERY CLEAR HERE IN THIS
STATEMENT.
WE ARE JOINED BY OUR PANEL OF
FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
INSIDERS.
STEPHANIE GRISHAM SEVERED AS
PRESS SECRETARY AND ALYSSA
FARRAH AND OLIVIA TROY WAS
DIRECTOR TO VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE.
ALL OF YOU HAVE BEEN ON THE
INSIDE OF THIS AS WELL AS
SIGNATURE HERE TALKING ABOUT IT.
SARAH, LET ME START WITH YOU.
YOUR NAME COMES UP IN THIS
DOCUMENT SEVERAL TIMES BUT LET
ME GIVE THE CONTEXT.
MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF THE WHITE
HOUSE STAFF WERE INCREDIBLY
FORTHCOMING, INCLUDING SARAH
MATTHEWS.
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO SEE ALL OF
THIS IN BLACK AND WHITE?
>> DEFINITELY A FULL CIRCLE
MOMENT.
I RESIGNED ON THE EVENING OF
JANUARY 6th DISTURBED BY THE
EVENTS OF THAT DAY AND TRUMP'S
DECISION TO NOT CALL OFF THE
MOB, AND NOW SEEING THE WHOLE
INVESTIGATION THAT THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE HAS CONDUCTED,
IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN I THOUGHT
WHEN I RESIGN THAT HAD EVENING
SO NOW TO BE AT THIS PLACE, I
NEVER THOUGHT THAT I WOULD BE A
WITNESS TESTIFYING AGAINST MY
FORMER BOSS, BUT DEFINITELY VERY
SURREAL.
>> ALYSSA, LOOKING THROUGH THIS.
WE ALSO LOOK IN HERE.
THEY TALK ABOUT LAWYERS WHO WERE
REPRESENTING MAYBE YOU ALL BUT
OTHERS LIKE YOU WHO WERE
TESTIFYING WHEN WERE SAYING SAY
YOU DON'T RECALL WHEN YOU DO
RECALL AND SAYING OH, WE'LL GIVE
YOU A REALLY GOOD JOB.
IN ONE CASE ONE OF THE LAWYERS
FOR SOMEBODY TESTIFIED THE
CLIENT WAS OFFERED POTENTIAL
EMPLOYMENT THAT WOULD MAKE HER
FINANCIALLY VERY COMFORTABLE.
>> I'M GOING TO BE VERY SERIOUS
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
LOOKS INTO WHAT AMOUNTS TO IN MY
OPINION WITNESS TAMPERING.
WE HEARD FROM COLLEAGUES OF OUR
WHO TRIED TO TESTIFY AND FELT
LIKE THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO TELL
THE WHOLE TRUTH AND CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON WAS VERY OPEN ABOUT
THAT.
SOME OF US GOT OUR OWN ATTORNEYS
AND WERE ABLE TO TELL THE WHOLE
TRUTH.
THAT'S THE UNDERTOLD PART OF
THAT STORY, HOW MUCH MORE PEOPLE
WOULD SHARE IF THEY DIDN'T FEEL
INTIMIDATED OR HAVE THE PROPER
REPRESENTATION.
>> STEPHANIE, YOU LOOK AT THIS
IN BLACK AND WHITE.
SOMEONE WAS ABOUT TO BE DEPOSED
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE.
THEY GET A CALL.
A PERSON WANTS TO LET ME KNOW OF
YOUR DEPOSITION AND THAT HE'S
THINKING ABOUT YOU.
HE KNOWS YOU'RE A TEAM PLAYER,
YOU'RE LOYAL AND YOU'LL DO THE
RIGHT THING.
IS THIS THE
>> I DIDN'T PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCE IT BECAUSE I
DISAPPEARED.
I PERSONALLY RESIGNED THAT DAY
AND I DISAPPEARED TO WRITE MY
BOOK ACTUALLY, BUT THAT IS THE
THING WE CAN ALL AGREE.
WE HAVE ALL BEEN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TO SPEAK OUT, YOU DON'T DO IT.
YOU DON'T DO IT, AND IT WOULD BE
MET WITH THAT KIND OF VAEILED
THREAT.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME AT ALL.
I'M WITH ALYSSA.
I'LL BE INTERESTED TO SEE WHO
GOT BULLIED OR TALKED TO.
>> ONE THING JUST KIND OF ON
THAT, I THINK A LOT OF US WERE
EXPECTING TO SEE SOME WHITE
HOUSE STAFF NAMES NAMED TODAY AS
WELL FOR CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
I ACTUALLY THINK IT WAS
STRATEGICALLY WISE TO NOT NAME
THEM SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THIS
IS GOING TO CREATE A SCRAMBLE OF
PEOPLE WE USED TO WORK WITH WHO
MAY HAVE LEGAL EXPOSURE.
>> WHEN JAMIE RASKIN JUST SAT
THERE AND LAID OUT THE CHARGES,
DONALD J. TRUMP AND JOHN
EASTMAN, AND ALL OF THEM
INCLUDED AND OTHERS.
>> I THINK TWOFOLD, I THINK
THAT'S CORRECT.
I THINK HOPEFULLY THIS KIND OF
GIVES PEOPLE A LITTLE BIT MORE
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD AND SAY,
LOOK.
THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THIS IS COMING MY WAY IF I DON'T
CONTINUE TO COOPERATE.
I ALSO HAVE TO SAY, LOOK.
I'M THINKING OF CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON TODAY, AND I HOPE
THIS IS VINDICATION FOR HER THAT
THIS IS BEING REFERRED IN THIS
WAY BECAUSE SHE DID STAND THERE
BRAVELY BY HERSELF AND TODAY
THERE WITH COURAGE, AND WAS
THREATENED ALONG THE WAY.
WE HAVE BEEN THERE WITH THE
JOBS, AND I'M THINKING BACK TO
THE JOB OFFERS THROWN YOUR WAY,
THAT WAS THROWN MY WAY WHEN I
WAS TRYING TO RESIGN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> REALLY?
>> THIS IS A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
THAT REPEATS ITSELF.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE THIS
PERTAINS TO CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
AS WELL.
THEY SAY HER TESTIMONY ADDED UP,
THAT PAT CIPOLLONE HAD BEEN
CRUCIAL IN VERIFYING, BUT NOT
EVERYBODY HAD BEEN FORTHCOMING.
KAYLEIGH McENANY, WE ALL KNOW
HER, AND IVANKA TRUMP HERSELF.
THAT STORY PERTAINS TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW, THAT
SOMEONE WHO WORKED FOR HER LAID
OUT HOW THE PRESIDENT HAD CALLED
THE VICE PRESIDENT A VULGAR
WORD, A WORD BEGINNING WITH
A "P," AND IVANKA TRUMP SAID SHE
HAD NO RECOLLECTION OF THAT.
THE COMMITTEE MAKING IT CLEAR
THEY DON'T THINK THAT ADDS UP.
>> I THINK THAT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
KIND OF STILL WORKING IN THE
INNER CIRCLE TOGETHER.
HALF OF THEM ARE ON THE AMERICA
FIRST POLICY ROSTER.
HALF OF THEM ARE DOING SPEECHES
TOGETHER, AND I THINK THAT TELLS
YOU WHERE THAT CIRCLE IS, BUT
THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS AND WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT WENT DOWN I
THINK IS HISTORIC.
I THINK IT'S BEING PUT ON THE
RECORD AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT, AND WHEN WE LOOK
AT 2024.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE, SARAH, THAT I
HAD NOT RAECALLED, AND THAT WAS
BILL STEPIEN.
YOU LOST, AND TRUMP KNEW THAT HE
LOST.
>> YES.
>> THEN HE SAID RUDY GIULIANI
KEPT COMING IN AND TRYING TO
BREAK INTO HIS OFFICE TO THE
POINT HE TELLS HIS ASSISTANT TO
LOCK HIS DOOR AND WON'T ALLOW
RUDY GIULIANI IN.
THAT REALLY STOOD OUT TO ME.
WAS THAT SOMETHING YOU WERE
AWARE OF, OR --?
>> I WASN'T AWARE OF THAT AT THE
TIME.
I KNEW THERE WERE FOLKS ON THE
CAMPAIGN SIDE LIKE BILL STEPIEN
AND OTHER LAWYERS WHO WERE
TELLING TRUMP WHAT HE DIDN'T
WANT TO HEAR WHICH WAS, YOU
KNOW, THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION, THAT HE
HAD LOST.
SO THEN, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE LIKE
RUDY GIULIANI WERE ABLE TO GET
IN THE EAR OF THE PRESIDENT,
FEED HIM THESE LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND THEN
WHAT'S SAD IS THE PRESIDENT
REPEATED THESE THINGS, AND THAT
IS WHAT SENT THE MOB TO THE
CAPITOL BECAUSE THOSE FOLKS WHO
STORMED THE CAPITOL BELIEVED
THESE LIES.
>> THEY DID, AND I MEAN, ALYSSA,
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
STEPIEN SAYS, MAYOR GIULIANI
TRIED TO GET IN HI OMY OFFICE A
ORDER HER, HIS ASSISTANT, TO
OPEN THE DOOR.
SHE DIDN'T.
SHE'S SMART ABOUT THAT.
I CAN JUST SEE THAT MOMENT.
>> BILL STEPIEN IS NO HERO.
HE'S A VERY TALENTED OPERATIVE,
BUT HE WENT ON TO WORK FOR
ELECTION DENIERS EVEN THOUGH HE
SPOKE TRUTH TO POWER TO SAY YOU
LOST, BUT YOU WORKED TO TRY TO
GET PEOPLE ELECTED WHO DENIED
THE ELECTION.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE TRYING TO
REFRAME THEIR NARRATIVE IN THE
WAY THAT THEY TALKED TO THE
COMMITTEE, BUT LOOK.
ONE FACT IS UNIVERSALLY TRUE,
AND I THINK WE ALL WITNESSED IT.
EVERYONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
DAY, PERHAPS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT KNEW WHAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY WAS WRONG, HISTORICALLY
UN-AMERICAN, AND UNPATRIOTIC.
MANY CHOSE NOT TO SAY THAT, AND
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THOSE WHO DID
THOUGH.
>> TODO YOU SEE SOME TRYING TO
REWRITE HISTORY?
>> WELL, SURE.
I HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF THAT AS
WELL.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THERE, BUT
TO PIGGYBACK OFF OF ALYSSA, I
THINK IT WAS INTERESTING.
I DON'T RECALL, SO I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WAS NEW TODAY OR NOT, BUT
THE FACT THAT HOPE HICKS SAID
PRIOR TO, YOU KNOW, THE
INSURRECTION THAT SHE WAS TRYING
TO SAY, PUT SOMETHING OUT.
TELL THEM THEY'RE GOING TO COME
PEACEFULLY SO THE FACT PEOPLE
WERE TRYING TO DO THAT
BEFOREHAND HIT HOME WITH ME.
I HOPE PEOPLE WERE WATCHING
TODAY BECAUSE THERE WERE A LOT
OF HEARINGS.
THERE WAS A LOT OF INFORMATION,
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT HE WAS
BEING TOLD WELL BEFORE, AND THEN
DID ALL THE HORRIBLE THINGS.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
AS THEY MADE CLEAR AND THEY HAVE
IN THEIR HEARINGS, THEY MADE
CLEAR, THEY ACKNOWLEDGED HE
KNEW.
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.